i believe about representation learning
or you can think of it that way
so kevin got his phd um
about a year ago with uh georgetown and
bowen and armando solar lazama at mit he
will be a
an assistant professor at cornell or
already is
but he's spending some time in a small
company and kevin did that
thank you for joining us we look forward
to your talk
thanks ross um let me just uh screech
here
um or can people hear me
yeah it's great to hear you and see
everything okay
all right um
so yeah thanks for organizing this
symposium series and i'll be talking
about
a system called dreamcoder which i uh
uh built over the past few years with my
collaborators
mainly kathy wong max knight matthias
lomier
um lucas marleis and my advisors armando
and josh
um so i i'm going to be talking about a
kind of program synthesis
called program induction which is really
a
way of thinking about knowledge
representation for ai systems
and the way you should think of it is
that we want to build ai systems that
represent their knowledge as programs
as symbolic code and a consequence of
that commitment is that if we're going
to be
doing any kind of learning we're going
to be adding to that body of knowledge
then that means that we're going to be
making new programs or doing program
synthesis
so from an ai point of view there's a
few reasons
why you would want to do program
reduction
so one of those reasons is
that programs tend to generalize
uh uh pretty strongly um like that's
kind of what it means to be an algorithm
that you can like run it on your inputs
and you'll keep on doing the same thing
um and because you can often like learn
because these programs tend to
extrapolate or then interpolate i mean
you can often learn them from much less
data
not all programs are interpretable as
i'll be discussing in this talk
but programs in general tend to be uh
more interpretable than other
representations um
for example contrast a programmatic
representation
of a 3d object like a drill in a cad
engine
um which has like parts and you can pull
apart and edit and things like that
with the analogous point cloud or mesh
representation
like what i've shown on the bottom the
program representation the
cad routine is way easier to recombine
and
recompose in all sorts of new ways than
the corresponding math representation
but really the most celebrated feature
of programs is the fact that they are
turing complete
that they're universally expressive and
that means that at least in
in theory like in principle they have
the expressive power
to uh capture the kinds of things that
are solved by intelligence um
so there's been a lot of successful
systems
which have been built which induce
programs um so
of course the most famous one that most
of you are probably familiar with is
this flashfield system
but because programs are universal you
just got to kind of change the
programming language to adapt to a new
domain
there's been other systems for example
the system called zelinsky which can
synthesize
these intricate 3d cad routines which
have like loops and things like that
and underneath the hood for all these
systems is some kind of domain specific
language
um which imparts like crucial prior
knowledge about what the kinds of
programs are going to look like
that are successful in this domain and
in practice if you want to get one of
these programming systems off the ground
you need to have
a good domain civic language as well as
usually a custom synthesis algorithm
that operates over that language
so even if you look just at like
graphics programs so all these systems
infer some kind of geometric or graphics
program from
from perceptual data all the programming
languages have a lot of similarities but
there's also key differences
um so i think that the the kind of
challenge that this poses to us as ai
researchers
is how can we make learning systems
which um can adapt the
programming language that they're
operating over in order to tune
themselves to some new domain
so i think of this as like a kind of
learning to learn because you're
learning to do program reduction
and you're using programming reduction
to do learning um
and from that viewpoint if our goal is
really acquiring that amazing
knowledge in order to induce some new
classic programs that means we have to
learn
something about the dsl we need to learn
completely here we're going to learn
like a library
so a library of abstractions or
subroutines but also
we need to learn how to deploy that
library at test time in order to solve
new problems
so this is like a inference strategy or
like a synthesis algorithm
so we have a system which learns both
these things directly
and i'm going to illustrate how it
learns a library
for doing list manipulations
in a very simple setting so
really imagine that you wanted to
induce a program which sorts a list of
numbers so you might give a
specification in terms of input outputs
such as those shown on the right and you
might initially give to the system
some generic but fairly spartan
set of components
which you can use to synthesize so
things like conditionals and map and
fold and stuff like that
so somehow we gotta breach the gap from
the
components on the left this initial
library to
a program which can solve the problem on
the right
now the system which uh solves this
problem doesn't look at just a single
uh synthesis task on isolation it's not
just
looking at sorting lists of numbers it's
also looking at
around 100 other problems some of which
are easy some which are hard
and it starts out trying to solve these
problems and as it solves some of the
easier ones
it then uses those to build out a
library of higher level routines
which we hope will eventually allow us
to sort list numbers
so for example after this algorithm has
run for a little while
it defines a new procedure in this
library
um here it was the fourth procedure that
it defined so i've called it concept
four
and concept four relies for example upon
the fold function which was built into
the initial primitives and
concept 4 is really the higher order
function filter so it takes a predicate
and a list
and filters out all the elements of that
list which do not satisfy that predicate
so filter is a nice function to have but
it's
not in and of itself like going to get
you
really far toward a sorting algorithm
now if you run this learning algorithm
longer
then what you see later is that the
13th function that it decides to add to
its library
is routine that builds on filter and
which computes the maximum elemental
list um
now this is almost uh
all the way to sorting like computing
the max is very useful
for sorting um and if you go
deeper into its learned library one of
the final routines that it learns
uh calculates the nth largest element of
a list
and once you have this routine it's very
easy to
express a solution to this sort list
problem
all you have to do is repeatedly call
concept 15. you just have to say you
know
get the first largest element and the
second largest element and the third and
so on
and then you've sorted your list um so
the solution that it
eventually finds is very compact and
interpretable
and does not take very long for the
synthesizer to discover but in principle
it would have been possible to solve
this problem without this
library learning so in particular you
could have
expressed the program that it found in
terms of the initial primitives that we
gave in the system
but this program is extremely long and
hard to understand
um on the surface it kind of doesn't
obviously even need to do with sorting
um you'd have to start it for a really
long time to figure that out
um and it's not just uh obfuscated
there's also like a deep sense of it's
like inaccessible
like there's no reasonably bounded
search that could like ever discover a
program
this long um certainly i don't know i
you know
you certainly can do this with like a uh
brute force search uh
so in particular the program that we
found the the short one in terms of
positive 15
uh the synthesizer can find in under 10
minutes but if you want to do brute
first
brute force search and try to find this
lengthy program it would take
far longer than the age of the universe
um
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to explain the algorithm which
built this library and which wrote the
code which solved this list sorting task
um so this algorithm is called
dreamcoder and the reason why it has
this name is because
it's uh structure and its mathematical
framing
is based on um uh
wake sleep algorithms which are
unsupervised methods for training neural
networks uh the most famous of which is
probably the helmholtz machine
so inspired by weight sleep algorithms
um
we have uh something which is called a
waking phase which corresponds
to running a synthesizer and we have a
pair of interleaved sleep phases
so in what i'm going to call abstraction
sleep we are going
to improve the library so we're going to
add new functions
um just like i was showing you earlier
where it's defining like filter and
compute maximum
and then we're going to have another
sleep phase which trains a neural
network
called a recognition model to help guide
the search over programs that occurs
during the synthesis phase or the
waking phase so from
a kind of beijing point of view what's
really going on here
is we observe a bunch of synthesis tasks
and i've shaded the tasks to mean that
we observe them
so we get to see some specifications and
we have to infer a program that solves
each of those specifications
these programs are unshaded which means
that we don't get to see them
and the highest level we also need to
infer a library which kind of unites all
these programs and says
uh here are the kinds of components
which are useful for writing programs
that solve tasks that look like this
so just to kind of first out of the
approach one way that you could imagine
doing inference in this model is to just
kind of
uh fix some library so pretend that you
observe the library just fix it
and then say okay now i want to infer
the best programs given that library
and then if you had some way of inducing
libraries you could pop back up and say
you know now i want to infer
a new library you could sort of
alternate this process
and eventually iterate until some
convergence point
so one twist that we're going to add
here is we're going to train a neural
network which as i said is called the
recognition model which is going to
learn to map
from a specification to a probability
distribution over the space of all
programs
and we'll assign more probability mass
to programs that it thinks are likely to
solve that task
so by training the neural network we're
going to effectively
guide the synthesizer and we're going to
be kind of amortizing the cost of
performing synthesis
so we sort of pay a cost for training
the neural net
and then that cost as a becoming
amortized
in the process of solving many synthesis
tasks
so this is the kind of aging perspective
on how dreamcoater operates
now if you look at this picture here
which i'm just going to put here on this
new slide there's really three things we
don't know
we don't know the programs we don't know
the library and
we don't know the neural network weights
and because there are three things we
don't know
that motivates a three-step iterative
learning procedure
where we hold uh two of those things
fixed
and then solve for the other one so this
iterative learning procedure corresponds
to the weight
abstraction and dreaming phases of this
algorithm
so during the waking phase or the
synthesis phase
what we do is we take a task so
for example input outputs from some
specification and we have some
current library and we pass that task to
the recognition model
which outputs a distribution over
programs which biases a search
over the space of ways you could combine
components from that library
and we search until we either hit a
timeout or until we find enough
solutions
to that task during the dreaming phase
of sleep we're going to
train our neural network our recognition
model
now the recognition model maps from
programs to tasks so it has to be
trained
on pairs of programs and tasks but we're
assuming that we don't actually get to
see any ground truth programs so we need
to
uh in a self-supervised way
get some programs as trainee data so the
simplest thing we could do
and here on the side what is marked as
replays is to
simply take programs that we found very
wicking and take the task
that they solved and teach the neural
network that when it sees that task that
it solved
it should predict the program we solve
it
so the problem with this though is that
in practice
we're often running the system on only
maybe 50 or 150
different tasks and that's not really
enough examples to train a high capacity
neural network
so another source of training data is to
take our library and just randomly
assemble components
until we get a program and then run that
program to see what it does
um and so uh the advantage of this
is that we can make as many random
programs as we want
so we have unlimited training data but
the disadvantage is that
random programs in general are not going
to be representative of the kinds of
programs you actually want to write
but as i'll show once the library
has changed itself so that it matches
the distribution of programs
that solve tasks in the domain these uh
so-called fantasies or random programs
end up being end up looking a lot like
the actual training data so it's like a
kind of domain randomization or data
augmentation
uh during the abstraction phase of sleep
we replay programs that we found during
wicking
and we refactor them in order to
extract reused uh parts of their syntax
trees
um so you can think of this as a kind of
compression where we're trying to
compress out
reuse syntactic patterns um
so i want to talk briefly about each of
these sleep phases
so in the abstraction phase of sleep
which you think is like learning parts
of a dsl in particular learning
a library of components it works as
follows
so imagine we had two tasks uh specifies
input outputs
on the left i'm showing you a task which
is take a list of numbers and double
each element
and on the right is a task which is take
a list of numbers and
decrement each element so during the
waking phase we could solve each of
these tasks
but imagine that we don't have the
higher order function map
instead we just have recursion
implemented via the y combinator
so with enough compute you can still
solve these problems
but the code you get out is hard to find
because long
and it's hard to look at these things
and see what they're doing because
they're very long programs
so during the abstraction phase of sleep
what we do is we pass these programs to
an algorithm
which builds a data structure that
represents a very large set of possible
ways of refactoring them
in this case it ends up considering on
the order of 10 to the 14
such refactorings and i've highlighted
in each of these boxes one refactoring
of those 10 to the 14
for each of those programs the part that
i've shaded in orange
is a subtree that these two refactorings
have in common
if you were to yank out that subtree and
add it to the library
then all of a sudden these programs
jointly would be much easier
to write down so we get more
joint compression if we added this
orange subtree to our library
um the orange subtree corresponds to the
higher order function map
so in this case um what's going on is we
gave it these two initial tasks
it didn't have map um it did a bunch of
search to find programs in terms of the
y combinator
um and then during the abstraction phase
of sleep it pulled out
some common uh expressions that these
two things could be refactored into
and in the process uh defined a
map and its library which could then be
used in subsequent wake cycles to solve
harder tasks
so 10 to the 14 is a terrifying number
but we don't actually
consider that many refactorings the key
insight is that most of these
refactorings actually
share a ton of common structure and you
can build a data structure which
combines ideas from equivalence graphs
and version space algebras
which exploits that massive sharing
and which allows uh these kinds of
refactorings
uh to be performed tractively
so i'll now talk about the neural
network and the ways in which it's
trained
during the dreaming phase of sleep
so i remember those training on
fantasies and replays
so we're just going to be focusing on
this broad system here
so the neural network takes a task and
you can think of it as outputting a
program that solves that task
but really a better way of thinking of
it is it takes a task and outputs a
distribution over programs
and you could then draw samples from
that distribution
so this kind of high level setup is
something
that lots of folks in the plml
community have uh thought about so and
there's
many different choices what the neural
network could be so for example it could
be an autoregressive
recurrent neural network such as the
robust fill system
it could be like a unigram model which
just predicts the probability
independent of all other
components in the program of using any
one component
so for example deep coder did something
uh very similar to the interior model
and this work by menon and govany
very explicitly like trained a unigram
model
so what we ended up finding empirically
is that
something that is kind of a happy medium
that works well here is a
bi-gram model over syntax trees and this
is a
probability distribution which predicts
the probability of a child node
conditioned on its parent and
which argument of that parent it is so
this is like a biogram because a bigram
conditions on
the immediate successor in a sequence
and here
is like a distribution over syntax trees
which conditions on the immediate
ancestor in the syntax tree so
child conditions only on parents in a
bigram
the next token traditions only on the
preceding token
so concretely imagine that we have some
program
where at the root we have a plus sign
then this bigram distribution
um predicts the probability of what its
left child should be
given that it's a plus sign and maybe it
predicts that it should almost certainly
be the number nine
it also predicts what the right child
should probably be
and here it decides to multiply and then
you can sort of recursively unroll this
at each time conditioning
only on the immediate parent in the
syntax tree
so there's a couple reasons why we do
this one is that
um similar to decoder we only have to
run our neural network once
because we're just trying to get a
bi-gram transition matrix
so that means that our synthesizer is
bottlenecked
not by how quickly we can run our neural
net or by
how fast our gpu is but instead by how
many cpus we have so we can then build a
parallel synthesizer which parallelizes
over cpus
the other advantage is that you can
learn to break a lot of syntactic
symmetries
uh for example you can learn to not
multiply by one by simply
zeroing out the probability of
generating a one
given that your parent node is a
multiplication
symbol so
now i'm going to talk about how these
two sleep phases interact
in a few different experimental domains
so in the paper on archive that i've
cited at the bottom uh we apply this to
a range of domains
um but i'm going to zoom in here on um
some planning and inverse graphics
domains a recursive programming domain
and an equation discovery domain so for
the inverse graphics domain
what we do is we give the system um a
corpus
of logo or turtle graphics images
and we give it a programming language
which has control over a pen
and it can also calculate like angles
and distances and its job is to draw
each of these pictures
by writing a single program for each
picture
now if you run this algorithm on this
data set
what happens is as follows so on the
left i'm showing
the initial logo graphics language given
to the system
on the right i'm showing a few sample
images that had to draw
and beneath each of them the code it
wrote to draw it and in the middle i'm
showing the library that it learned
in order to draw these kinds of pictures
so for instance when you're trying to
learn to draw this worthy beach ball
thing
what it does is it calls out to learn
function 8
and learn function 4. now if you look at
learn function 4
it is a parametric drawing routine which
generates uh spirals
and if you look at learn function eight
it's a
higher order function which takes
another drawing routine and repeatedly
runs it
while spinning around in a circle so
this makes a lot of sense because if you
look at this for the beach ball thing
um it kind of looks like a spiral that's
been like spun around in a circle
um so function 8 i think is kind of
interesting because it's really a higher
order function
and it corresponds to the geometric
concept of radial symmetry
so rather than bake in these kinds of
symmetry operators
as long as you have higher order
functions you can in principle like
learn these things inside of the library
if you look
at other routines in this library some
of them are
very interpretable and kind of
unsurprising they're things like
routines for drawing circles and
polygons
but other routines are a little weirder
and harder
to interpret like this uh parametric arc
drawing routine
um so the arc drawing routine um i don't
really have an english word for it but
the system nonetheless finds it like
useful
for explaining many of the images that
it has to draw
now this library that it's learning is
kind of like a representation of its
uh symbolic knowledge of the domain so
it's like
a vocabulary that's assembled for
expressing solutions
to these drawing problems but
at the same time that is growing out
this vocabulary it's also
uh learning statistical knowledge uh
that allows it to
map between problems and probability
distributions
and that statistical knowledge is
embedded in the weights of a neural
network
it's really helpful to also look at
how that neural network is growing over
time and
in particular how its training data is
changing over time
so recall that the neural network is
trained on fantasies or randomly
assembled programs
um so at the initial point of learning
these fantasies
we expect to be very simple and
unstructured so here are what these
dream programs look like uh prior to
learning a library
um so here i've color coded each of
these uh images to show how the system
drew it
starting with uh dark blue and ending in
light pink
um and most of these random programs are
relatively simple and unstructured these
would not be good training data for a
neural network
um so actually these are sort of the
most interesting examples from 150 draws
because most random programs before
learning are just
single line segments so
now we should look at um what random
programs look like
after learning so after it's built that
library
so after learning what you see is a kind
of uh
recombination or remixing of uh
latent subroutines that were in the data
and which it inferred
were good ways of explaining the images
that i was seeing
um now you might notice that these
images look more complex in the training
data
and that's because for fair comparison
with the previous slide these are again
the most interesting dreams from 150
samples
um but you should think to yourself you
know what do you want to train
your program synthesizer on do you want
to train it on data that looks like this
or do you want to train it on data that
looks like this so once it's
learned its library um that kind of
bootstraps the training data for the
neural network
so we can also train it not to draw
pictures by moving a pen over a canvas
but also to
build towers by moving a hand in a kind
of tetris-like world
so here we give it these construction
problems um
and if you look at this learn library
you see uh
kind of like higher order uh like
planning macros so these are kind of
like options
but they're parametric
and again we can look at the dreams
before learning
and we can look at the dreams after
learning and again what you see is that
learning this library gives better
training data for the neural network
so it's also helpful to look at the
system's learning trajectory over
successive weight sleep cycles so at the
initial point of learning
almost no problems are solvable only the
easiest problems can be solved
but then over successive like sleep
cycles the system is able to solve more
problems
learn a better library trainer a better
neural network
use that to solve more problems and so
on and so you get this kind of boost
dropping action
um now you might be thinking do you
really need both of these uh sleep
phases
but if you ablate either of them
interestingly you still get the same
bootstrapping action you just get
much lower asymptotic performance you
can also compare with a range of bass
lines
so i think that the most interesting
baseline here is the enumeration
baseline
which asks what would happen if you did
a huge amount
of search without any learning
whatsoever so in particular what if you
just ran
an enumerative synthesizer for 24 hours
per problem
here we are running it for 10 minutes
per problem and what you see is that
even with
more search uh like you still need
learning in order to get the ball
rolling
and if you look across many different
domains um the same kind of global
picture emerges
that uh learning unfolds in a kind of
bootstrapping way
over multiple wake sleep cycles and that
you really do need
both of these sleep phases in order to
get to the highest level of asymptotic
performance
so i think that the
reason why each of these uh sleep phases
does better why you need both of them
and not just one of them
um can be explained very intuitively um
and it's by
thinking about these three phases of the
algorithm as follows
so during waking we're kind of doing
like problem solving or synthesis
and as we solve more problems as we
successfully synthesize more
uh solutions we then have more training
data for the library
but as you saw in the pre and post
learning examples for the dreams
a better library gives better training
data
for the recognition model for the neural
network
but the recognition model is being used
to
guide the combinatorial search over all
programs
so a better recognition model means that
you can solve more problems during
waking
so you get this kind of virtuous cycle
where when one part of the system
improves it kind of echoes and
reverberates
throughout the rest of the system and
that uh and that you know
sort of causes them to interact
synergistically um
so this story is i think fairly
intuitive and there's also some
empirical data
to back it up that empirical data comes
from looking at the evolution of the
library structure
over the system's learning trajectory so
here what i'm plotting
on the x-axis is a statistic of the
library structure
namely its depth when viewed as a
network
and on the y-axis i'm plotting how many
problems the system can solve
when it has that library um
in darker shade i'm showing what's going
on early in training and in
brighter shade i'm showing what's going
on later in learning so as the system
learns more as it goes through more of
these cycles the libraries get deeper
and also the libraries tend to solve
more problems
now here's what happens if you ablate
the
neural network so if you get rid of the
dream phase of sleep
so as you can see uh two things happen
one is that the neural networks be sorry
the libraries become more shallow
and also for a given library depth
you still solve fewer problems so
by having the neural network we both get
better libraries
because we get deeper libraries and
those are correlated with performance
but also for a given library depth
there's an extra bump to performance
from the neural network so adding the
neural network
improves the libraries that you get and
analogous but weaker trends fold if you
look at a different statistic
of the library structure in particular
it's uh size
um so in what i've talked about so far
um we built in a uh
what was still like a a very
customisable language you know like a
language for local graphics
or a language for moving a hand around
in a tetris-like world
but in principle you know we should be
able to start with a more generic kind
of programming language
and then use the exact same algorithm in
order to enrich it and move it closer to
something like a
domain specific language so
i'm going to look at two case studies
which explore this one which starts with
something like a modern functional
programming language
and then learns a language for vector
algebra and deserts
and then one which starts with a very
basic kind of lisp and then tries to
learn something which looks like that
modern functional language
so for physics what we did is we took
equations from ap physics and mcat cheat
sheets
and we simulated random data so we took
each equation
and ran it with random input outputs and
then
um got kind of like simulated data for
each equation
and then we asked the system to come up
with programs which can fit
each of those simulated data sets
so here's a few example equations on the
right and on the left are the
things that we initialize the system
with and crucially you can see that it
has some
domain specific stuff like the number pi
um but it also is missing some important
things for example it has
no knowledge of vectors and instead
it just knows about lists of numbers so
we encode
all vectors as lists of numbers and we
should expect to see that the system
um discovers that it's more compressive
to define vector algebra routines
so indeed that's roughly what we see in
the sort of first layer of its learn
library
we see basic vector algebra components
like addition
and subtraction of vectors and as we go
deeper into this library we see that it
can build on top of those routines
in order to define things that
look a little bit less like vector
algebra and a little bit more like
uh basic physics so things like
integrating second derivatives over time
um and if you go into like the final
layer of the library you see
stuff that is definitely physics and
definitely not just vector algebra stuff
like
schemas for inverse square laws or
templates for calculating the period of
oscillators
um so once it has this library it can
solve most of these cheat sheet
physics problems and usually the code it
writes
sort of maps intuitively onto how like
as a person you might
parse um that equation so for example
for coulomb's law
it uses its inverse square law schema
and composes that
with its vector subtraction operation um
but if you were to translate that into
the initial primitives
um then it would not in any obvious way
have anything to do
with uh coulomb's law it would just look
like a a mess of
maps and false um so
by learning this library uh these
solutions became more interpretable and
also
search became more tractable um
so here instead of uh building in
functional programming primitives
we wanted to learn them from a
more generic and smaller basis um so
particularly uh we give it things like
cons car and quitter
and also crucially recursion via the y
combinator
and we gave it like a problem set of
around two dozen
or so uh functional programming
exercises
um so interestingly in the very first
layer of its learned library
the thing that it defines the things
that defined in its like first
sleep cycle where these two functions
one of them is called fold which
recursively consumes a list
and one of them is called unfold which
recursively generates a list
so each of these can be defined in terms
of the y combinator
and um in a very precise technical sense
um they kind of are like a basis set
that spans the ways that you could
operate recursively over lists and once
you have fold and unfold you
don't actually need the y combinator in
order to do
uh recursions over lists um and
so it turns out that the system decides
to never use the y combinator again
besides that's like too cumbersome and
instead to
build up routines on top of map and fold
so familiar things
like map and filter which are folds um
and these sort of unfamiliar unfolds
that it decides to define
things like this routine i called count
two and countdown and unfold list
but also familiar unfolds like uh if you
know range from python that's an example
of unfold
in addition to these kind of
unconventional unfolds that decided to
define this range routine
as well as things that bring together
the full and unfold families like
indexing into a list
so the style of coding where instead of
doing explicit recursion
you use these higher level operators
well then unfold is sometimes called
origami programming
and i really like this um uh acquisition
here by
jeremy gibbons um although i the idea
itself is uh older
um than this citation here um
and while it's interesting that it kind
of um
retraced this style i think that the uh
broader point that's being illustrated
is that you're kind of not stuck with
the symbols that you start with
so here uh you know i i told it i used
the y combinator
um but then it's possible for it to
instead define other symbols on top of
those
and then proceed to ignore the y
combinator for the rest of its execution
um so this experiment took an unusual
amount of compute
because it was trying to bootstrap
itself from
a very minimal basis in particular this
took approximately an entire
year of cpu time um i don't think that
you know you should actually
run library learning algorithms for an
entire year this is more of a kind of
sanity check
to make sure that like the refactoring
algorithm can handle higher order
functions and things like that
and to show that in principle um you
know these these things can be learned
from uh more basic starting points
um so you know i think that actually you
know you should build in things like map
and fold because we know that these are
generically useful for many different
kinds of problems so there's a couple
different lessons
that i think uh we can take away from
this one is that
uh learning a library can interact
synergistically with neural program
synthesis
each of them kind of bootstraps the
other
the other is that programs
are not necessarily interpretable i mean
think of like assembly code versus
python code
but here what i'm arguing is that if we
grow the language
based on uh training data then it can be
both more friendly for synthesis so it
can make problems more tractable
and also it can make um things more
understandable
for humans um the last lesson here is
that you know you can maybe learn from
scratch maybe you could in theory
start with like combinatory logic or
something like that and try to learn a
library which
could solve lots of things but i think
that would be totally nuts and it would
take tons of compute
and the nice thing about
synthesis is that it makes it very
convenient to build in the kinds of
things that
we know our good ideas and then learn on
top
of uh those things that we
we built in um so
that's it and i'd like to thank the
organizers and my collaborators
and i'll take questions thank you kevin
for the great talk
uh please i would like to encourage
attendees to ask questions it seems like
the radu is ready
yeah so very nice very inspiring talk
kevin so
so the main idea is of the library is
that uh
you have the maximum amount of sharing
uh among the codes
yeah so so you can think of it as
actually the set of capabilities
uh let's say uh of an agent
so and you can grow now one one
interesting question is how
you know in order to to get to more
tasks and more things
you have to give them more data input
data am i right
so how do you come up with that so
you know yeah yeah so i think that
what you want is something which covers
like a
wide range of difficulty levels and
something which also
uh makes up a consistent domain so for
example
if you had like very easy graph search
problems
and very difficult like image generation
problems
um that clearly wouldn't work um so
uh for example one thing like like one
of our domains
which i didn't discuss in the talk was
this uh generative regular expression
domain
where we crawled a bunch of csv files
from the web
and this kind of naturally had like
a spectrum of difficulty because some
csv files
are very simple and small like maybe
they're just
like monetary amounts and others are
more complicated like it might be like
addresses
and so the tasks here were to generate
um each of these csv columns um and so
you end up getting like a nice
spectrum of difficulty uh and also you
get
like a consistent domain because you
tend to see like reuse of concepts
across csv columns you know like uh
you might have like one column which is
just years and like another column
which is like the entire an entire date
so you can like reuse the year concept
in the like entire date uh
concept um so so you need some
something like that one thing that i
think would be interesting to explore
and that we haven't explored
would be to kind of look at like actual
programming like like actual
uh pl problem sets or something like
that um like get like real lisp
exercises
um i think that you know that might not
work quite as well because
um uh when human students are doing
these problem sets they also get a bunch
of natural language
that's uh informing how they think about
it it's not like they're learning all of
these ingredient outputs
so one thing that uh kathy wang
one of my main collaborators on this has
been exploring is ways that you could
augment this algorithm with
uh natural language site information so
in addition to
um uh getting like input outputs you
would also get like a natural language
description
of um what the task is supposed to be
solving um
and so you know i think that that that
kind of um
[Music]
something like that might uh
help it work better in uh more
human-like settings when you're not just
learning from input outputs
thank you very much very very
interesting
do we have additional questions
i have a question um
how do you so so in your examples the
the concepts that you're learning
through this refactoring
are very nicely interpretable but
um i mean how come they're interpretable
is there kind of some reason behind
because i could imagine that it would be
other refactorings that would be
less meaningful yeah yeah um
so first i should say that um they're
not all interpretable
um you know uh
i i would say like a little more than a
little more than half are like very easy
to interpret
but then there's a bunch of them which
are useful for the synthesizer and also
impressive um but where i have i
definitely would not like intuit
that this is like the right library
routine um so like that that arc
that weird like parametric arc thing in
the drawing example
um is one instance of that um and the
uh you know the the ones that i hide in
the talk
like you know like give the end largest
element of a list um
tend to be like biased towards
interpretability because i you know want
to be able to show an example of people
who say like oh yes i see
like it like makes sense um but there's
you know i also want to show like the
the ones that don't work um so
i like i think that the reason why he's
finding these
like weird kind of esoteric looking
routine sometimes
is because when humans are thinking
about how to carve up the world into
concepts like
we're not just trying to find the most
compressive representation um so for
example
in the numpy library um uh
we have we can multiply matrices in
several ways
we can take the transposon matrix in
several ways and any of that redundancy
is actually is actually coming at the
expense
of uh compression so you know numpy
would be strictly more compressive
if there was exactly one way to do every
single operation
um so whatever kind of inductive biases
that
we as human coders bring to the table it
uh it's it's something
which is uh more sophisticated than just
compression
thanks yeah
uh kevin one quick question uh in your
ablation study you showed that the
recognition model alone is more powerful
than the abstractions alone
uh right so if you had to pick one you
would just use that
is there a reason for that is it perhaps
a function of the algorithm that you use
to then
synthesize the programs um
i think it's actually just because
bigrams ended up working a lot better
than we expected
um so earlier in the work that this
builds on which we called
ec squared and published a couple years
ago we did like a unigram model
and the neural network by itself was
strictly inferior
to library learning by itself um
so i i think that what happened is we
just souped up the neural net
more than we souped up the library
learning um i don't think there's like a
deep principle that like one of them has
to be
uh strictly better on its own than the
other
on its own so you don't think there is
perhaps some fundamental
uh thing like the neural model actually
remembers the abstraction sort of
encodes the abstraction and sort of as a
macro expansion so to speak
um produces that sort of expansion that
the library learning uh captures in a
new primitive okay actually actually
you're right um
there is a there is a deep thing of
light here which is the neural network
in principle can encode everything
that the library learning can encode but
the library learning and principle
cannot encode
everything that the neural network is
doing um so that's not true for like our
background model
but for something like a transformer or
like
a lstm in theory the lstm
implicitly inside of its ways could just
kind of like memorize these library
routines
and the bi-gram cannot do it because you
really have just the context of the
current node right
right yeah
right but also conditioned by the
example right or not yeah
yeah yeah it is okay yeah well i hope
we'll get to talk about it some more
uh other more questions the
fantastic four talks i really want to
thank all speakers
for dedicating their time and everybody
else for joining us
and thank you again have a nice day
thank you very much
bye thank you bye
thank you bye
you